[Music]
[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
like the video and comment hey guys what
you're seeing right now is the first
trailer of the first season of game
terms as it usually goes so the footage
we see in the trailer so we get to see
sooner or later when the show airs
however one scene from this trailer was
left behind in the final release the
scene in question is a flashback
depicting the execution of Ned Stark's
father and older brother record and
Brennan start by the Mad King Aerys the
same features record being cooked alive
inside his own armor while his son
Brandon hid the noose tight around his
neck strangling himself to death trying
to reach a sword that was placed beyond
his grip the execution of the two men is
what set of Robert's rebellion
it's a ruthless sequence for sure and no
doubt will be tough to watch but it
hasn't aired on the series to date with
the show coming to its end it only makes
sense for the scene to find the air now
some of you might say that since the
scene did not air in the first season
there's no need for it to air in the
final season as well and I would agree
with you if the scene was not a
flashback that can be included in any
season whatsoever which is exactly what
his scene is with that being said let's
take a deep look into the unaired scene
that will most likely see in the final
season as I already said it's about Lord
Rickard and Brandon stark being put to
death on orders of the Mad King but
let's get a bit back it all started when
the heir to the Iron Throne Prince
Rhaegar Targaryen for unknown reasons
abducted Lyanna Stark
the daughter of Rickard stark Lord of
Winterfell and warden of the north and
here away in Dorne later in the series
we learned that Leanna was not kidnapped
by Rhaegar she loved him and he loved
her but that's what we the audience know
not the people of the Seven Kingdoms
except for brain and Sam this event was
extremely scandalous as Lena was
betrothed to Lord Robert Baratheon to
Lord paramount to the Stormlands and
Rhaegar was already married to princess
Elia Martell with whom he had two
children after Lena's abduction Ronettes
older brother Brandon was enraged and
rode to King's Landing demanding the
release of his sister and the death of
Rhaegar Erised arrested him for treason
and called for his father to come to the
capital to ransom him when Lord Rickard
comply
the air is now utterly mad arrested him
for treason as well
Lord Rickard demanded a trial by Comet
and there is declared fire the champion
of the House Targaryen the Mad King had
record burned with the Pyromancer
lighting a fire beneath him while record
was dressed in his armor as he burned
Brandon was brought into the throne room
a leather cord attached to strangulation
device was wrapped around his neck as
Brandon was made to watch his father die
Aerys told brain and his father was a
dead man but there was a chance to save
him a long serve was placed on the floor
just out of Brandon's reach and more he
struggled to reach it the more the court
tightened around his throat Brandon
stark strangled himself trying to save
his father who was roasted alive in his
own armor the entire court stood and
watched is the trusted a taking place so
Jaime Lannister and the Kingsguard among
them the horrific and unjust way in
which record and Brandon were killed
along with Lina's abduction led to
houses Baratheon stark in reign
rebelling against the Iron Throne
their death left at her to inherit
records responsibilities becoming the
new Lord of Winterfell and warden of the
north
Brandon had been engaged to Catelyn
Tully and it also inherited his
brother's bride hostile is soon after
joined rebellion after the marriages of
NATO Catelyn and January into Lysa Tully
House Lannister joined very late when it
became obvious that the rebels would win
ensure this event is what changed
Westeros and one of the main events that
led to Robert's rebellion which resulted
at the end of the Targaryen dynasty it's
very important event to say at least
George Arman stated that even though
they are currently working on game
thrones prequels the Roberts abelian is
most definitely not one of them George
explained that by the time Song of Ice
and Fire and by the time the game of
Thrones show is over we'll know
everything and will witness every
important event that occurred during
this time period
he finished by saying it would feel too
much like a feistel tale this confirms
that we'll get a few flashbacks that
will summarize all the important events
that trigger the Robert's abelian as
well as the event that happened during
the rebellion long story short will most
likely get to finally see this flashback
in the final season the campaign to
overthrow the Targaryen began when the
Mad King killed Ned Stark's father and
brother but it might not be entirely the
mad Kings fault according to the very
popular theory the reason why Aerys kept
repeating the phrase burned em all
because brain in episode three the
battle winner fell upon realizing
they're losing the battle hit Shellback
and tried to convince the Mad King that
the White Walkers are real telling him
to burn the army of the dead before they
become too strong
that's what bran might have been doing
during an entire episode three instead
vespers only heightened the mad Kings
already uncontrollable paranoia leading
him to kill the Starks and start a cycle
of warfare that still continues in
estrus let's put it like this is this a
six episode three brain realizes that
our skin hearing during his visions of
the past in season eight episode three
he doesn't yet see a way to defeat the
night king so he attempts to reason with
him carries and tries to warn him of the
approaching army of the Dead whispering
to him to burn them all before they kill
us all
the King hears those whispers and is
driven mad by them the Mad King burns
brains grandfather alive and kills
brands uncle well brain tries to stop
him but all he hears is whispers brain
says the events that occur just before
the show in motion just as it started
events in the show after walking in on
Cersei and Jaime that's a theory in
which brain would not change the past he
would only realize it's him and whispers
that drove every star garyun into the
madness and it's him who caused the
deaths of his uncle and grandfather
similar as to what happened with horror
in season six episode five brain warg
into young villus resulting by brain
working into present-day horror as well
holder under brains control held brain
in ear and their escape out of the cave
mera desperate and scared screams hold
the door still in the vision of the past
of NFL brain sees young villas collapse
that are his mine returns to his body
young holder keeps screaming hold the
door repeatedly until it slurs into
horror basically breast possession of
Elias in his vision of the past broke
young Melissa's mind and here's the
echoes of Meera screams which made his
mind simple and only capable of
repeating a form of the last words he
heard before his death horror horror was
always horror for as long as brain
knowing brain might be a reason that
young village became horror but the key
point is that brain did not actually
change the past
he said the past of course that will
become the present the existing present
time did not change horror did not
become horror just now he's been that
way all along in this case brain is not
changing the course of history
he is playing his part in a
predetermined chain of events everything
brain has done in the past
already been done and we can already
feel the effects of all those actions in
the present the question is what other
things has brain affected in the past
for the whispers Matt King heard that
eventually caused him to go mad were
actually brains whispers was it brain
himself who made the Mad King mad the
book reader says well as show viewers
alike have heard many tales of the Mad
King then his father and John's
grandfather the ruler of the Seven
Kingdoms before Robert Baratheon usurp
the throne
Aerys was known as unstable and paranoid
convinced that those around him were
conspiring
however aries ii was in fact not all
this mad or somewhat arrogant and
hot-tempered he was also charming and
ambitious in his earlier age may his
reign started he made Ren recover from
the events at summer hall and from the
war
Harry Stephen proclaimed that his goal
was to be cold there is great orators
the wines however he didn't started
hearing voices that eventually made him
mad and paranoid
we know that the Mad King was repeatedly
saying burn them all in the later stages
of his life could it be a holded or
incident 2.0 could it be the brain
thinking there's no way to defeat a
night king in the Battle of Winterfell
went back into the time and whisper to
him send armies beyond the wall and
burned all of the army of the dead
before it's too late or something along
those lines
witcher's then kept saying repeatedly
until it's lured in to burn them all as
already pointed out the king was not
always mad then one day something
happened that got him obsessed with a
particular phrase that caused him to
mentally slip it's definitely not out of
the realm of possibilities that reason
why Aerys kept repeating the phrase
burned them all is because branch held
back and tried to warn him of the
approaching White Walkers there's
another theory which is actually a
theory of mine according to which you'll
see a huge twist regarding of how much
influence bran can have over the past
given his tendency to ignore the advice
so wiser people and his irresponsible
use of his powers there's a good chance
that we could see bran attempting to
change the past let's take a look on a
scene from season 6 episode 3 as Ned
runs into the Tavor to finally in our
brains calls out to him that stops to
look around but it's confused because he
cannot find the source of voice before
brain can discover what's in the Tavor
for him sell the trailer and brings both
of them out of the past it's very
important to highlight that van brain
question whether his father heard him
the three-eyed raven did not denied
ability of that being true he had maybe
maybe he heard the women he had me the
past is always written the English drama
in fact he seemed to think that it could
be the case but nevertheless he Pony
brain to leave the vision as soon as
possible
whereupon he warned brain not to
interfere with the past maybe he knew
that brain had the power to make contact
with other people in this vision and did
not want brain to accidentally change
the course of history
if naturally did here his future sons
was then brain could in fact be able to
change the past which would
automatically change the present as well
in my opinion brain has already changed
the past by calling out to his father it
might have not been a significant change
but it could still prove that he's able
to do so let me remind you that brain
called out to his father in episode 3 of
season six
however season six finale proved that
brain has actually rewritten the past as
we can see that Ned now always hears
brain and turns around so there
certainly is a chance that brain can
actually change the past and in some way
communicate with people from different
time periods and if sure this would be a
major game change brain will do exactly
what the three-eyed Raven warned him not
to do
he'll interfere with the past and it
will result with making burning down
whole capital which would explain these
brains vision where it's of the past or
the future all prophecies in-game
internals don't literally come true
visions on the other hand do we know
this for a fact as in the sixth episode
of the sixth season brain received
multiple visions of the past and future
events and one of his visions from the
future already came through in the
season six finale brains vision of the
exploding wildfire the remaining two
visions are yet to be seen at the share
of a dragon flying over King's Landing
and the one image brain sees King's
Landing a mentor with an empty throne
room that has its roof blown off the
question we all need to ask is was this
vision of the throne room really a
vision of the future event or rather a
vision of the past event as you can see
in those visions the throne room still
has a seven-point instant window above
the armed Trump however ever since
Cersei destroyed the entire faith
militant there is no seven pointed star
above the arm throne in case you've not
noticed shortly after the coronation of
Cersei Lannister the Great Hall changed
significantly the seven point eight
starts and when necessary place to the
Lancer sigil with the lion facing
towards the
as well as the seven-pointed star above
the throne itself being replaced with
the sigil of house lannister showing
stars his new reign so he brains and
aeneas vision of the throne room was a
vision of a future event then crown
would have to change its ruler and that
ruler would have to bring the
seven-point it starts back and place it
on the windows taking into account that
neither John nor Dany are influenced by
the faith of the seven possibility of
either of them taking the throne and
redecorating the windows seems very
unlikely to say at least upon watching
the show multiple times and upon
reconsidering all the facts and hints I
made a theory that brains and Dana's
vision of the throne room is not one of
the visions of the future events but
rather a vision of the past event what
I'm proposing is that red keep will not
get destroyed by anyone in present but
rather by the Mad King and brain in the
past if this theory of mine comes sure
even though most of the current
characters would still be around it
would certainly change the course of
history and present for example brain
would still be born to Ned and Catelyn
as the Mad King already kill Ned's
brother that was supposed to marry
Catelyn before he burned down the
Capitol however some of the main
characters like for example Jaime would
be burned alive along with the Mad King
as he was in the red cape as well and
this would resulted some main characters
that are dead to be alive in the present
one of those would be Ned Stark since
with Jaime being killed King Joffrey
would not exist in a rewritten history
and that Stark would not be beheaded for
false treason you'll explain why brain
sees the destroyed throne room with the
seven-point stars being above the earth
throne even though there is not one ever
since earth to destroy the high Sparrow
and the faith militant brains and
Danny's vision of what we assume is a
vision of a future event would turn out
to be one of the visions of the past
events anyways one of the most important
events that led to Robert's rebellion
execution of the Starks was said to be
featured in a flashback scene in the
first season footage of the scene
appeared in the very first trailer fear
and blood but has not appeared in any
aired episode of the first season nor
any season whatsoever or at least not
yet the scene was cut from season 1 for
time restrictions but since it's already
been filmed and since it's a flashback
will most likely get to see it in the
final season and since there are only
three episodes left there's a huge
chance we'll see it in the upcoming
fourth episode it will provide some key
backstory to the rebellion and give a
better looking at the Mad King what
exactly caused him to do what
didn't why was it the Targaryen madness
or was it brain stark George RR Martin's
said we'll learn everything about the
Roberts abelian what caused it why how
and all the important stuff this scene
will probably cause the confusion among
the audience way back in the first
season but now that we actually know
what we are looking at it'd be an
interesting addition for the final
season I think all of us would like to
see this flashback along with a few
answers that will come with it
stay tuned for season 8 episode 4 video
that is coming later today and check out
my episode 3 breakdown video that I
published yesterday if you haven't
already and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace